several members of liquid are very low
and kuroky getting right-click forced to
pop in supernovas are able to jump in
they find the killing 2gh there's the
rabbit counterplay though he's been
going to be enough we're able to find it
so much damage
miracle chosen as well as dominating for
him oh lordy more the rabbit wasn't
going to be enough to say that Hank that
X was still going down son be right
clerical the Magic Man dozen again
[Music]
[Applause]
liquid is definitely back late Chris
dominant just some of these games really
has to just make you sit back and just
go wow it looks like the Reaper now BG
Jo the big table the combo yeah later
bpj there were some heroes there a
second ago he came down but he does fill
up by back Roshan is almost a miracle
and my control cries take it down
miracle will stack achieve all the
mostly in plays they say cannon rotk
careful even aggressive mad as hell but
they can't run him down he eats the
cheese and runs away what a player needs
to finish off the Roshan bet with five
heroes trip up a neurotic ODB he gets
the stun as I go did they find the
tornado is he gonna go down he almost
falls we find the cold
what a great college of the word was
there at 5:30 Oh God sound of me
burrowed trying to run Sam age Tama man
blink God if you found him again
what oh no he's just constantly got it
is this inside there has a quick miracle
is going to back out in a way Raven
really well played and now they're
controlling up that ember spirit if they
can bring them down to who would be so
huge he gets the Jays and walked away
everybody on low HP here but they're not
going to end up falling this whole
miracle jumps back in a cake boundary or
so relocated and that's going to heal up
miracle a little bit further and now the
Jade for same base wants to find him
urn keeping him alive because the safety
gets the kill
setting up on them those trying to go in
the
so at least for the moment from a
compliment but mine controls now shown
up they throw us a big ol see there's
the roar on to rotk is already a race
code but there's the damage they have
enough to take him down and then we're
also gone she is going to follow the
freeze well my humble man is just a
monster in these fights eat another
scale of Oh burrow on the miracle
they've got the duel as well kuroky get
the rabbit off there with the hard stock
now they turn it around the first finger
is after the game in the mid lane just
being a menace right now to rotk I
actually think he's employment us I
don't know out of anyone on liquid in
this early game it kind of just like
yeah you die like oh my god
have mercy and you can also prevent a
lot of the demon terribly oh really good
play there they relocate out the amber
though and it was well set up because
now the rest of liquid is coming in from
the southeast and up the medusa doesn't
get the hopi off a few center out as
well connecting onto several and it
looks like they're not all dropping
super low they get to relocate back in a
way by the IO so it's gonna be fine for
the moment the only one dead so far is
the natural fear it looks like you
should be okay for the moment as Raven
it's a lucky integer in there and
they'll take in the damage from IO oh
another one that can t quite find it for
business plus though they're pretty
close to this leaf I said yes so getting
those 370 to the spirit oh my god that
was eh
okay that was ridiculously good wisp way
[Music]
thanks for watching if you want more
great content be sure to hit that
subscribe button